today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza at
1811 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on
the way to the beach gray block get that
hitter I wanna let you guys know that I
will be in Boston next week are actually
Medford on Thursday night at the
chevalier theater and that's a place
where you can see live comedy like
myself you can get those tickets at
theof on comm slash tour tou r this past
weekend is gratefully brought to you by
Skillshare think about a skill you have
walking backwards or looking for
something and finding it or remembering
who people are well those are easy now
you can learn a great new skill
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators or creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career that's right
instead of going back to college and
doing all that funny money and spinning
all it at getting the dorm room you know
joining intermurals hurting your leg in
a game no one even cared about you can
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing or
even illustration join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free think of all the
things you don't know now you can know
them to sign up go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von again go to Skillshare
dot-com slash Theo von to start your two
months now that's Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo von today's episode is with a
gentleman male comedian who has who has
certainly been
through it all he has a new tour that's
actually gonna be in st. Louis this
Friday night tomorrow you can get
tickets to see him and and I'm happy
he's here in studio today it is mr. Dane
Cook
[Music]
what was was Danny ak what was like a
name that fans cuz fans pick up my kind
of name sometime yeah and I feel like
that what they called himself I feel
like it never turns out well yeah I had
Danny Danny acts actually they tried to
do that and I'd killed that oh yeah no
no and then the Dame train yeah it's
what I joined one day and I was like
okay that sounds kind of cool get on the
Dane train get off the danger like a
[ __ ] Doobie Brothers song or
something like that I was that was and
I'm glad that [ __ ] for a little bit but
and a train it gives a fan something to
get off of like our your support or
something you know right we're gonna
bring it into the station yeah you go
home you have yourself a nice meal yeah
and then get back on the damn train and
we'll head to the next destination yeah
at least it's open till like if people
are like hey you know I've been on here
for a couple years I'm ready to step off
and then you know I'm ready to get on
you know it like gives the opportunity
because otherwise yeah what if somebody
gets a tattoo that they're a day niak
and then six years later they're like
people have gotten tattoos I mean I've
seen people with my face on their inner
thigh Wow like such a weird if I was
gonna get your face anywhere on my body
I don't know if I'd go Phi yeah you know
maybe just go back and you kind of make
it like you know just a presentation if
you're you know down by the local pool
but yeah a little bit of the past then
or then it's like yeah something in the
front thigh right in here man or woman
it was uh it was a dude yeah yeah it was
a guy he he actually had a lot of
comedians on his body was it was like a
tribute to all things comedy oh that's
pretty cool yeah man it was awesome Wow
what are your fans call you or call
themselves do they are they trying to
come up with like do we have anything
Nick I got one okay what about this
ready the crispy wontons hey what's up
all the crispy wontons out there your
chinese fans would really really play
into that exactly pretty good we only
have I think one Chinese fan all right
yeah well you know what you're the
crispy Vaughn
you're the start yeah cuz that seems
kind of yelling it gets kind of crazy
when you start having like fans and
supporters you know yeah I really when I
turned a corner of being absolutely you
know out of any kind of conversation to
having people you know wanted like know
more about me beyond comedy that's when
it got a little funky because I was like
oh I'm really different from you know
the persona so that's the only part that
was tricky I love the correspondence
with fans when we were talking shop
talking comedy talking bits talking you
know whatever is coming up next when
they were like what makes you sad yeah
like I don't know if I could share that
information
oh that's all what our whole podcast is
based on my whole podcast is based on
like you know just things that I've
thought or felt or yeah yeah well now
like now I'm like the opposite now I can
dig super deep and I've kind of been
through every incarnation of a career so
it's like now this is perfect because
I've 29 years later grown into the idea
of like being introspective is actually
way more exciting than just being
observant of behavior yeah yeah yeah
because I was reading like some people
cuz you're definitely like a performer
you know and I've always been big on
I've never been a like I respect joke
writers but I like Wow I personally
enjoy watching a performer right you
know it's why I love like Sebastian
Maniscalco yes you know it's like it's
one of the reasons why i like watching
crystal yeah like i like watching
something her yeah you know and it
seemed like but performers it seems like
don't get as much credit from the media
at all yeah it's similar to like how
most of the time like bombastic movies
that are like action-oriented
doesn't get the same kind of critical
acclaim as something that's just you
know a little dour and yeah when in
dramatic it's bonkers it's like the same
amount of effort energy creativity
impact all that stuff needs to come
together in order to make an act like
that and I'm the same way I grew up
Jerry you know Jerry Lewis
Steve Martin dice
you know PIPA Martin Short I just like
people that went for it ya know and but
as I got a little bit older started to
realize odd if you can if you can work
this craft and try to build yourself up
there's a way to actually have that and
then bring something that's written or
more introspective to it which is kind
of cool now and you feel like so chief
like you're doing that more with your
new tour with this new tour that you're
going on now yeah it's different between
it like if you're a fan coming out you
know that came out you know that was on
the Dane train in the beginning you know
that was on because it was really like a
rock it was that like a rocket ship when
you cuz I mean it really wasn't because
it was a slow burn it probably felt that
way for a lot of people that you know or
suddenly were like smacked in the face
of like who's this named Dane Cook I
keep hearing the college market I had
for all of the 90s been just like chip
and went out and you know just like
party and after with everybody and just
trying to ingratiate myself and and and
also it was just fun you know cuz I was
a kid you know you know making a little
money having some fun but I always
understood the the campaign element of
it which is if I want to you know be
elected comedian of the year until my
service is over like I'm gonna have to
get as many people on board without a TV
show without I didn't have a lot of
supply k-- the just for all I was
talking to Bruce Hills at just for
laughs I said you never had me on one
new faces I just didn't have any of the
industries of course s support early and
it's probably good because it just made
me have to cultivate my own means they
don't get it seems like yes I can wonder
why they don't I think a lot of them yet
like scares them or something to believe
that it makes it feel like it's not
about the entertainment anymore it's
just about what the industry kind of
wants to push sometimes right right it's
it's what's relevant right now today and
it and I I'm probably I'm not going to
be a hypocrite I've been guilty of it
myself where it's like you just glom on
to something because everybody's so
enthusiastic about it but with time and
you're gonna learn this as well and I've
talked to people before me that
in this corner there's a there's a
moment there's a process during your
career where you start to earn a
pedigree while you start to you're
seasoned and that's actually when a
performer I think is more interesting
you know the trajectory it's great shiny
new exciting what they do with that and
how we evolve and how we communicate
with each other and then to the crowd I
feel like a 30 years in almost that I'm
just getting good I'm just using all the
tools in the arsenal to tell the kind of
stories that I've always hoped to tell
and we to answer your question directly
what's different about the tour now is
yeah there's more introspection because
I have more hindsight to play off
observational II but it's my height size
it's it's my story my UPS my downs and
the thing that was the probably the
trickiest about this tour and this time
was I just didn't want it to be a
one-man show I love one-man shows but I
didn't want my show to be something less
than what people had seen before I
wanted the same LPM s laughs per minute
with all the new tools that I had in my
arsenal which took a little it'll took a
little time to get around that that that
turn so but it seems like oh I mean like
Divina comedies a one-man show when you
sue when you say you don't want it to be
a one-man show like what do you mean
though yeah like I didn't want it to be
introspective to the point where it
wasn't very entertaining yeah you know I
wondered if you saw me 20 years ago the
greatest compliment I've gotten this
last weekend might or just recently
started is people saying seen you eight
times was at Madison Square Garden was
at this was out that this is my favorite
show I've seen you do and people saying
honestly I didn't know you could do that
I wasn't sure if you could exceed my
expectations again but the show is as
good if not better than other shows I've
seen you do in the past and that that's
the greatest as a comedian except for
people quote in your [ __ ] and saying it
back to you which is fun you feel like
Mark Twain for a little bit right it's
it's really it's it's kind of one of the
coolest aspects of still being able to
do it at the level that I
been doing it yeah it's cool do you feel
you've always seemed to me like kind of
abhi like a lone wolf kind of do you
feel that I think that in I don't feel
that in life I feel like if anything I
it's an embarrassment of riches with how
many great mentors and friends that I
have in in and out of comedy but when
you're 28 years old and you hit the
stratosphere nobody can talk to you
about that nobody understands it and
perception takes over because then
people start to believe that maybe
you're not accessible and in who is
accessible to you you don't find out two
years later bullshitters people want to
make a little scratch right people that
see something to gain scoundrels [ __ ]
it's like most Eisley cantina from Star
Wars like all the scum and villainy
wants to seek you out because they want
they want a piece of a sparkle man yeah
everybody wants some of the sparkle you
see somebody with sparkle it's like oh
[ __ ] I want to I want to glimmer with
that person but now what happens like
but Dee it's always seem like you do you
have this thing really it's like you you
have to I have to do this myself because
it always seems like you are this
different kind of like you're like Pluto
kind of a little bit not that you're out
pushed to the outside yeah but that you
choose to kind of be in this you know
like yeah you don't know if I'm a planet
or a ball of ice yeah I'm a thing or
just like a rumor that science made up
you know yes yeah you don't really know
like is this guy a planet is this guy a
ball of ice I like you see you see him
like that you seem so just a regular
comedian coming up yeah it's like who is
just like everybody else seems a little
bit more accessible a little bit more
you feel bad I don't feel about with a
lot of comedians
yeah maybe and that could is but your
graduating my profession your graduating
class in my in my graduating class I
wouldn't feel that way about the comics
I came up with him around but I think it
maybe it's generational when I met
people ahead of me I was intimidated to
go up and talk to them you know what I
did I did the same thing people
to put on me which is they don't want to
talk to me why would that person care
about me why would I'd see David Spade
or Chris Rock when I was young in New
York why would they care about talking
to me so what did I do I projected
they're probably too cool for school
yeah until finally you're at the comic
table with somebody or we're John like
this and you're like oh [ __ ] no that's
it's not that crazy yeah no it's
definitely I don't feel like the warden
of the north
like some Game of Thrones thing where
I'm I'm on Pluto or something on the far
outside I do like that that's part of
the interpretation of what I am because
it's a whole hell of a lot more
interesting to be somebody who where
people want to put their hand on their
chin and go let's go then somebody was
like yeah yeah yeah we got it we got it
I never wanted to be that I thought I
was that I actually thought I was like
yo yo we get it you move around a lot on
stage and trying to write some stuff we
get it and dismissed but if anything the
polarizing was like oh good yeah I'm not
milquetoast I'm not [ __ ] boring right
I'm interesting I'm almost like a little
bit of a good guy bad guy you don't know
how I'm Lance what I feel like with you
it seemed like the antihero yeah I mean
you know what it was fun it's been fun
has that been a goal it seems like
because you I feel like you you
definitely seem like obviously super
aware especially comedians or hyper
aware yes who we are and what's going on
I think anyway a lot of in super
sensitive and super sensitive yeah which
is one of the reasons you have to be
hyper aware because you have to know are
those things kind of go together because
it's like you're so aware that it makes
you overly sensitive because you're
taking in so much that there's so many
ways that you could feel that we could
feel offended yeah easily so we're so
you know aware and then so sensitive at
the same time yeah I think that we're a
lot of comics I think what we do is we
you know we ruminate and we are we're
seeing 10 different incarnations of what
could be and what does that do that that
that then makes you start preparing for
what if a happens what if B happens we
exert a lot of energy even in our stuff
dude it is exhausting yeah and hyper
where yes Austin having to constantly
like protect yourself from like seven
different ways of feeling uncomfortable
right you know you ever hear those
stories about Jim Carrey early on in his
career when he would
he had this and did you ever work with
him no I never had the opportunity to
work with him but I've I've worked with
people that have collaborated with him
and I I usually don't just on hearsay
I need like a few different people to
validate and I started hearing from a
few different folks that like back in
the day when he would go to a party if
he thought people were gonna [ __ ] with
him doing what we're doing thinking up
so and so is gonna be there what if she
says this what if he says that that he
would sit and pre-plan some stuff to you
know roast you or haze you right so you
couldn't hurt him some eight-mile [ __ ]
man he had like it already on tap he'd
practice you know imagine the energy
that that took because what if you had
eleven people yeah your [ __ ] neck
right he yeah he that's the neck you
wore yeah I could see him yeah here we
go
he would go deep cuts yeah on that [ __ ]
and and I understand a little bit of
that I think that I think that the you
know if you're thinking about a career
in comedy what you got to realize is
it's it's an amazing community it's a
brotherhood I mean that guys and girls
but it's also really cutthroat and it's
also sometimes it's very participatory
and sometimes it's very isolating you
know and you got to know what you need
to be at what point right
and that's hard to know and I had to
learn the hard way which was pretty much
on my own but then meeting mentors along
the years that were the knowledge that
they passed on to me helped me to figure
out what a career really is and there's
gonna be a crest and you're gonna dip
and it's gonna come up and then it
there's so many more elements than just
what we do on stage right you know when
you so when your career like blew up you
know cuz I mean you had what I mean and
I've talked about this even in
discussions about you when you weren't
around that you were like kind of the
Steve Martin of our time in the way that
well some of you know that somebody no
one has that I mean that's such a rare
thing that somebody has you know has
that trajectory yeah yeah it's just a
rare thing it happens to someone
you know and it happened to you and not
saying that you're you know obviously
you did the work but what happens like
with your ego in that part that's
something we always talk about it
because that one of my scariest things
to me is my own ego right because it's
such a it's me and I know that I'm
crafty and then I'm cunning yeah and so
I know that my ego is that as well right
like what happened like with the like
did you find for yourself what I found
was maybe a little different because I
had grown up so as an introvert I had
grown up with a lot of fear I grew up as
a self-loathing
manok I was in an environment of there
was alcoholism in my family yeah there's
a lot heaviness and I felt like I grew
up fast so the years that I spent doing
stand-up leading up to what would
seemingly be an overnight sensation 15
years later the ego stuff really wasn't
like a bravado or some kind of cockiness
it was really more of oh I'm finally
starting to feel like I can love myself
because I obtained something in life
where I didn't really know what I would
get to you know I pipe dreamed a lot of
stuff Steve Martin and dice and seeing
these guys definitely always have those
in your head especially if you're in
this business and you're seeing other
people have those things yeah and so I
think that too if I'm if I'm
understanding correctly it's like to me
like ego was like I'd be at the cellar
when I was still new and Chris Rock
would come in he bumped me he bump
anybody and that was that was like that
was part of it that was kind of like a
rite of passage as a comedian like okay
some big star bigger stars gonna come in
and so when I made it I was like oh I
can do that too
you know I can walk into the Laugh
Factory which is primarily where I would
just go and feel like I can do what I
want this is I've arrived so that was
something I needed to get through the
rotating door about to realize like no
they're still actually like it's still
procedural and you can still have
respect for your peers and there's a way
to do that that's more appropriate than
just a barnstorming a club and then
right you know so I
I got my knocks I learned some lessons
learned earlier yeah yeah yeah and only
because certain names and some odd names
you know would reach out and I can't do
that man you know you don't want you
don't want to do that you want to try to
play it like this or and so I you know I
learned as I went and now I try to kind
of what we're doing here pass on to
whoever the next girl or guy is coming
up to say like you know when people say
stay humble that's no [ __ ] you know
really try to you know keep yourself as
modest and you know it's nice to be self
affirming but you got a you got a you
got to be able to like if you're gonna
get a a huge level of of power in in any
industry really like how you manage that
in how it it reverberates off you to
others that impacts you years later when
that person says hey thanks for being
cool to me yeah you know thanks for
being I'm a more time like Tosh he got
really mad at me we were I didn't never
was really close to him and we were in
the Laugh Factory Lobby once and I
usually talk out of school but like this
is one of those stories that and I think
I had put my hand out to him and he was
like no man no I need you in my life he
said something that was really kind of
harsh and I was like Daniel what I'm
just you know Congrats on the success
and all that and he was not interested
in having that conversation because I
had not been I had not been cordial to
him coming up I probably didn't take the
time on many nights at the factory to to
hobnob or just yeah just to I had not
realized that the level of influence
that I had that that younger comedians
at that moment not now but at that
moment like that would hurt them if I
were to walk by and not acknowledge them
but I wasn't doing it to hurt anybody I
was just still an introvert in many ways
right you know it's it's a man it's
[ __ ] it's perplexing in a paradox
sometimes even you know for me we had a
very deep conversation off pod and you
know we're we're we're complex you know
we're complex means you and I have never
been like clothes
but we just seen each other clubs talk
to a few times and and yeah and then I
came up to your house and and we hung
out that time yeah it was definitely
interesting because I didn't know yeah
it's like I feel like other comedians
are you kind of get a vibe from and you
kind of get an understanding of and you
just kind of seem like that like that
rare element that's kind of like well
what's going on with this guy like this
guy this guy's out this guy's kind of
seems like a lone wolf to me yeah I
guess that in terms of how I came up in
comedy that's a fair assessment because
I wasn't in a pack that was all doing
arenas and and Billboard charts and
top-selling platinum albums I I was
alone yeah I was really alone there
wasn't another person dice was 25 years
ahead of me having done Madison Square
Garden 1990 and I bumped him to omit
Mulberry Street pizza when I was like it
was like oh 506 and everything I was by
myself just having a slice just [ __ ]
sitting there you know napkins on my
face he sat right in front of me and I
got to you know have this conversation
with an icon somebody I looked up to and
and I felt like finally I was talking
with somebody who really understood what
I was talking about the hardships that
within the loneliness you know there
there was some loneliness I was like I
got here because I wanted to be in the
community and share but I didn't know I
was gonna seemingly skyrocket to where
people felt like a disappointment I
wanted to I thought that was good for
the business of all comedy right you
know because in the 90s comedy albums
were dead
everybody was telling me comedy was kind
of like you know after the boom of the
80s everybody told me they're like
comedy isn't like you know it was
oversaturated Comedy Central wasn't
putting on people that were really
seasoned and Yeti and so there was a
period of time where comedy was a little
bit bottom of the totem pole and I felt
like hey I'm I think I'm helping to shed
light on a new generation of comedy fans
yeah so outside perspective very
different about what people felt of me
to what I was hoping that I was
emulating out there for others you know
yeah
and jealousy probably was huge I mean I
can only imagine that like Jeff
cuz everybody was a little bit jealous
the Dane Cook I think
you know I think that what happened was
a lot of comics would say to me man I'm
so sick of DJs and people that are
interviewing me for my show I'm trying
to build saying literally saying why
don't you do what Dane does yeah why
aren't you and it was frustrating
why heard you say on stage one time this
one of the most interesting things I've
ever heard someone say on stage
you said yeah I've been going to therapy
a lot recently and it's interesting that
I'll sit down i sat down in the
therapists office for the first time and
they're like oh Dane Cook I've heard a
lot I've heard your name a lot in here
from other comedians yeah and that was
like such an interesting I just remember
hearing that man and that was such an
interesting thing yeah it was it was
weird
you know I remember that moment and
being like because he had worked with a
lot of comedians I was recommended by it
right yeah yeah the kimete comedy
community like you should talk to him
because he he gets it he knows the world
of comedy his opening line literally was
your name comes up a lot in here man
yeah it's like the vulnerability in that
moment of being like been wanting to
know what are they source of course that
would be so bizarre because then it's
like there's so much of you going on
outside of you right lots of you and
such a conversation of you outside of
you right and it wasn't till sometime
that certain comics had you know come to
me and said one comedian she was shoe so
I I don't want a name-dropper if she
wants to come forward and say Bobby
Whitney Cummings but it was not winning
but I love Whitney but this comedian
came to me and just said you know I it
took me a while and I was one of the
people that bashed you I misjudged you I
and she's like a lot of that was my own
feeling of not getting to you know what
I was hoping the fear you know it's
really like everything comes back to
love and fear man what drives us oh yeah
and what we you know what we want to
hold on to and and what we want to pass
up on why do you think you were like
easy to hate okay question well look I
was like young and wearing [ __ ] cool
junior it's like did you ever be honest
dude yeah I never wore fur okay faux fur
whoa is that first hopefully I would
assume being from su jugo it's real fur
dude that's Paul Revere country you guys
have earned the real fur but did you
ever wear fur no I did not no no we
didn't but my mom and some fur so I
probably did throw one of my mom's but
not once you got it popular no once I
once I made it I was it was like you
know tight shirts and you know the image
that I was trying to create Steve Martin
the white suit the the the dichotomy of
being like hey I'm dressed up really
nice but I'm being like wacky and and
then dice of course the element of of
like badass and cool Eddie Murphy in the
you know leather outfit I was figuring
out hey you know what my thing is like
I'm I'm coming up with this next
generation in dudes or more fashionista
in many ways then you know in the past
so I just found my niche and I played up
on that and then I I could understand
years later looking back like oh my god
I wouldn't have liked that guy
you know it's it's you know hindsight is
an incredible incredibly prolific thing
and you don't know at the time you just
think you're you know I don't know just
you're doing the best you can to try to
create an image that that resonates yeah
you know and you did a great job so at
certain points because when you say like
you know the gel Waseem did it a feel I
wasn't I wasn't looking at that I was
looking at 20,000 people I wasn't
looking at the one guy in the comment
section who was right of course yeah you
know so looking the messer
square garden you're looking at the the
proof that was in front of you yeah was
that everything I'm doing is right yeah
it was like I was just looking at the
love from the fans that I had found or
who found me so it really didn't hit me
until many many years later of like oh
wow there's really some genuine
animosity and it's just up to me to have
conversations like this with my peers
with the Brotherhood of Comedy to say
I'm accessible and you know you know if
you're a fan I'm accessible you could
DME I right everybody back so yeah
people write me and say hey man I'm
having a shitty day and I go here's what
you need to do
yes I'm super sensitive and I'm
empathetic to
that so the perception of me very
different than who I am when I'm just
you know at home kicking it yeah yeah
it's interesting yeah cuz that's what I
mean yeah if I'm real candid it was just
like yeah what is daint like Dane seems
like this I don't know yeah like this
kind of like this Pluto kind of like
this thing where people don't know but
for some reason people have felt rubbed
the wrong way you know
yeah then also has probably had the
ability to gain garner a huge amount of
jealousy over time as well so yeah
there's a lot of factors in there I bet
it was probably hard to sift through
some of that if you even wanted to look
at it yeah it was it was like because it
it didn't it wasn't even though it
wasn't affecting me directly in terms of
like business it affected like my fans
didn't like feeling like they were yeah
then if you were a Dane fan then it was
like weird
right there was a period where it's like
people were like hey am i I say I like
you and then I get attacked by other
people yeah but we use I'm in a
wheelchair because yeah Madison Square
Garden 20,000 see what you start to
realize what's going on here's the
here's the breakthrough breaking news in
what everybody learns when you become
successful and what you're learning you
know you right now you're in the UH pink
cloud phase everything's you know
everybody's fighting in discovering and
passing around everything is mediocre
everything every single thing is
mediocre Arrowsmith I love them there's
somebody going and I don't it's not my
thing
you can't name a book a magician nobody
athlete a name a magician a magician's
you know can we just omit images are
comedians arch-nemesis that should be
Wells is it yeah it should be a movie
dude and it definitely should be a movie
who else could our arch-nemesis be no
that's it and have you win that's it
that run right there but I interrupted
but I don't know everything is you find
out success introduces you to mediocrity
because then everybody outside of your
realm is gonna tell you why you're not
that great in what
talks about you you know you can we're
watching careers right now of people
let's just say in the last five years
and what do they do they get white-hot
and then you know and then it's like the
spanking machine everybody's gonna get
tagged and we're gonna find things out
that we don't like about them and then
what happens is your your fan base the
bottom of the V right here there's still
you know pretty much rock-solid in place
most of them and then everybody out here
is in the business of telling you yeah
we don't care all right and they wanted
to tell you and they're gonna reach out
to tell you all we can do just come up
with the next set next joke get up on
stage try to have a few more laughs with
our friends family and then do one more
show and that's that's what I'm doing
yeah we definitely seem to be really
fearless you know that's for sure like
just because I grew up in fear to
continue to keep your head down and keep
going grew up in fear grow when you grew
up in a fear-based
which I was then man just you know once
I once I found this conduit comedy once
I had that it was like the dilithium
crystal I had [ __ ] superpowers I had
this ability to actually be present and
important to people when I didn't even
feel important to myself right it took a
long time for all those things to equate
a well-rounded healthy lifestyle
on and off stage you know to be able to
have great conversations like this yeah
you know do you um did you have an idea
what you thought it like being a star
was there something like that before you
like hit like a level of stardom
popularity oh what a great question man
that that I remember Rob you know seeing
guys like Robin Williams playing like
GARP and like a Warlick arena guard yeah
that's one of my favorite books of all
time love it book amazing the film you
know awesome he was awesome and I was
looking at a lot of comedic actors and
admiring that they could tell different
kinds of story they could make you laugh
maybe they could make you cry
to me that was like an interesting route
for a career so what I did and where it
plays into the question is like I I took
my foot off the gas of what I knew
people had discovered me as and was like
I'm gonna downshift and try to go in
that direction so I can have some more
credibility and outside of comedy
deconstructed myself really in the mid
you know 2000 hear me like with films
and stuff like that with me at work
because then I started getting some
opportunity to do things that were very
different from stand-up based on my
stand-up and Kevin Costner was a fan of
my stand-up and then said do you want to
play a serial killer in this movie with
me and it was like suddenly that was
when I felt a certain level of stardom
when I was not so much from the comedy
ever but from the being received in a
this all comes back to inclusion and
feeling isolated as a kid you know Kevin
Costner's and Demi Moore's and Juliette
Binoche and Steve Carell people that I
love to watch them do things that were
so drastically different we're now
saying hey you you know right yeah you
ever then you're gonna marry one of us
so that's when I started to feel a bit
of oh wow I I'm in a I'm in a different
circle right an inner circle and do you
do you feel like then you start treating
people different like like was it was
over point you felt like like looking
back like oh I was an [ __ ] you know I
never felt like I was an [ __ ] I never
felt like I had never gotten to a place
where I like I had seen some other
comedians in some other behaviors you
know there was any Griffin is who
there's there are some magicians out
there I'd [ __ ]
Siegfried and Tiger face whatever that
guy's name was about uh I saw some
behavior and other not even just
comedians but just in other celebrities
you know having been in LA for bed and I
thought it was really deplorable and I
wanted to be a person that if you could
approach me if you felt like I was
approachable that you know there was
something to be gleaned from both my
success and failure so I I never felt
like an [ __ ] I
I would listen to people talk about you
know Joan Rivers I'd never met and she
called me an [ __ ] on Stern I'd never
met her I never made her Joan Rivers
joke I respected that woman yeah she you
know he was cool build it in and cool
and funny and always funny she used all
the racial slurs once on TMZ until one
of my favorite clips I'll watch it at
nights and that's for bed put on some
creams and then your top he's like some
buddies of this and some buddies of this
and some buddies of this and some
buddies of this and people's need to get
used to it well Joan you know called me
an [ __ ] and I remember I was you
never met her never met her never met
her and I was man I was like mortified
why did you think that
oh I either a I'm such an [ __ ] that
it's reached Joan Rivers like the rumor
of it know that what is going on that
people think this or just that I become
a name that people for some reason
associate with it you know what if I was
gonna get really if I was gonna go deep
into like the the the human element did
the it'd super it'd what's going on with
this I would say I the one thing I
didn't realize how to do was reach out
early in my career when I broke through
to to celebrate some of the comedian's
that came before me if I met you I would
I would I met dice at the pizza pies and
and I can only I'm guess I'm guessing
but maybe it maybe it hurt her that I
had arrived and maybe didn't shout her
out right you know cuz we're all so
[ __ ] sensitive yeah and what I've
learned about her from other people as
hey man she was she was very sensitive
to see where were all that and so the
having people call you an [ __ ] from
time to time is it was actually kind of
it was confusing
was it uplifting in a weird way though
was a party or ego or part of you I mean
it part of any of our ego or like at
least they're talking about me
well the the part that you because
you've had and I ask you this because
you've had some I mean you know there's
not anybody else that I could think of
that's had the same story that you've
had that's being considered you know
being ostracized in a way where people
think you're like the bad guy or an
[ __ ] or whatever is for me I can only
talk about my experience but for me it
was
like good this is an armor to keep the
people that have hurt me my whole life
away because they're a little scare to
me because they think I'm something
beyond just a regular guy which I'm just
a regular dude I'm just funny yeah an
hour and a half on stage and otherwise
I'm pretty basic you know I'm jeans and
t-shirt kind of guy and you know so that
to that extent I didn't mind I didn't
mind everybody having an opinion on me
and I didn't really mind if it was harsh
it just started to hurt when my fans
were really including my family you know
even my family like why this tabloid say
this about you were that's when it
started get a little confusing yeah cuz
I was like oh I'm just here to make
people laugh and you know I get it you
know buddy loves everything right people
don't love you but it was a weird you
know even looking back and talking about
it now it's still like what did I ever
do to anybody except just try to get
laughs the greatest thing that we can do
is try to get laughs you know yeah I'm
trying to it wasn't like I'd get laughs
and people would be withering and dying
and it's like give me all the power of
laughs right where it's like you would
leave an empty [ __ ] theater of just
corpses and you're like I'm an [ __ ]
I steal Souls it was just like no I just
want to make you forget about your
[ __ ] hardship for a little bit and if
people take issue with that then that's
what other people think of you is none
of your business
yeah you know what I try to I try to
implement that yeah I don't know why I
wonder why that thing why that thing
surrounded you so much then that it was
like armor the first time yeah I just
wonder why that surrounded you so but it
doesn't now it's just kind of funny
because if you talk to people now or
even somebody talks to you it's like no
once you talk to me and once you hang
with me be like oh maze he's pretty
level-headed you know I'm not a person
that has a lot of foibles otherwise man
I'm right I'm pretty uh you know I'm a
I'm a Boston kid and we say it like it
is and wear our heart on our sleeves and
I'm not into playing a character I'm
into my journey for the next many years
my life is like
be more present how can I be more real
how can I be more authentic yeah you
know organic that's that's my journey
now Wow
yeah it's interesting man it's such a
yeah cuz after we hung out I was like I
was like I don't know what I don't know
if you know I didn't know what thing I
was like Dane seemed so like normal and
and a knitted I had never and I told you
my preconceived notion to you yeah I was
very honest with you about saying hey
man I prejudged you as well I thought
like oh this is a guy that's like trying
to make it out of some other career and
yeah is he really a purist and and I was
you know I I wrongly did the same thing
yeah I took that card you left my house
that day and I was like I could grab a
lunch with that guy yeah I like him you
know you're really you're deep you're a
deep guy and you're [ __ ] funny
you know you're you're you're funny you
deliver on stage everybody knows that
everybody at about it so I admire that
but I like that you can do this right
you know I wish in some ways I had more
of this maybe around that time right
where the [ __ ] were you Theal you could
have helped come on crispy Vaughn tongs
let's go hashtag crispy Vaughn tons
let's go to we have fans of submitted
questions they love this okay so and I
actually had one too you okay you talked
about or you've never drank or smoked or
done a drug at all fact it's like when
you were at your darkest did that even
cross your mind is like a something to
turn to no plus he did why not no I just
never it was not it truly was not
something that was on my radar and
growing up as a you know I'm an adult
child I'm an alcoholic yeah so I would
be an alcoholic I would definitely be an
alcohol you might be just a dry one be
I'm not but I'm not addicted I don't
have an addictive personality outside so
I don't know if I would that's a good
but I'm intense
yeah I'm intense you know competitive
with myself I think I say years ago if I
did drink I'd probably need to be the
drunkest person in the room because it's
like I know I just have to you want to
win I want to win I want to show myself
that I can do more but it never it never
was very interesting to me
it wasn't my thing you could even
sometimes people with alcoholic parents
they end up repeating the same patterns
I think it's like impressive well my mom
said to me one day your dad was really
brilliant he was a brilliant guy he was
a BC graduate in the business man she
said just and she goes and he [ __ ] up
because he gets in his own way and he he
breaks everything down that he was
building up and so I was like if I don't
imbibe maybe I can build up and not have
the breakdown right portion so you know
but I might start doing heroin man I've
been thinking about it oh dude Ivan do
you know what I'm at that age Roger will
probably help oh yeah
I could see it a little here I mean you
take a little weight off though I don't
know if your face but I wouldn't mind
that that would be but do you find you
have it do you have like an obsessive
given addiction you think with working
out or like an obsessive like cuz you
always are like you definitely seem
jacked no I don't I mean I don't have
some I don't have like a regiment
I do love working out because it's good
for my brain yeah I think a lot of when
I'm like doing cardio and coming up with
ideas you know I do have a lot of energy
I'm you know the energy people see on
stage it's not put on right that that's
love of the game energy when I get up
there I have to temper it sometimes I'm
so excited yeah I think maybe that's one
thing that makes you like confuse or has
made you confusing to people I think
your energy is just different it's very
frenetic you have this like you know
it's very different than a guy you would
think maybe see a guy doing comedy it's
like an anomaly in a way yeah I don't
know i guess i watch other comics that
you know have energy and I guess maybe
because how I came up I can look at
somebody else and go this is this is uh
this is organic this is like the they
love the movement and stuff not as a not
as a character or a lair right but
they're just so enthused to be you know
and then the whole you know ego of
having people around you love you and
care about what you're saying on top of
the artistry of performing man it's it's
it can be very um it could be elusive
and it could also be very addictive yeah
you know yeah let's hear this cool
vo dang what's going on guys had a quick
question for you what is your most proud
moment as a comedian well just a moment
that might stand out to you or give you
the most joy that's it Thank You
gang hey gang man you've had a lot to
pick from we'll let you choose first you
me go first okay um I think it would
probably have to no I know it would be
the I posted twice but the first time I
hosted Saturday Night Live yeah because
isn't that what happened was that I'm
gonna give you the the abridged version
cuz it's actually more convoluted but I
wanted to be on the show for years saw
when I was a kid and was like that's
where I belong this circus of freaks and
whatever these weird characters and wigs
even weird wigs
yeah who does want to wear a [ __ ]
weird wig and go to work and like to
avoid right I was like I love that now
whatever that outlet is I need to plug
into that so that's a lunch lady live
too I would I would watch the show and I
would dream about doing the show and
then years later Lauren Michaels came
and saw me at the comic strip in New
York City my career was already starting
to really roll we were talking about
maybe potentially doing like a Billy
Crystal one season thing right come in
and just be like a comic for one year on
there and do skits and stuff but that
kind of fell through and so then I said
to Lauren that night after we talked at
the comic strip I said Lauren I yeah I'd
love to host and he said to me he's like
yeah that's not gonna happen and I was
like why and he goes cuz that's not
that's not how we do it anymore I go
yeah but Carlin in in Pryor and all
these guys like they would do the
monologue and it was different cause it
was stand-up not a skit and he's like
yeah that's it's it's passe we're not
doing it and then four months later
retaliation came out number four on the
Billboard charts I'm in a hotel in Vegas
for the Comedy Festival Lorne Michaels
he called me up hello hey man you're
hosting gonna give me a date right
so Wow what did you do after young with
the phone be honest a jerk-off or not
[ __ ] four times in a row I didn't
even have anything inning at the end my
phone just air game oh dude yeah and
Fetty came out of my [ __ ] hole oh yeah
that's called Apollo 17 and it went this
[ __ ] there's nothing at the end
that's one that blew I like that where
you got the Apollo 17 Pluto there's kind
of a whole astrological and astronomy
the honestly do you think you jerked off
or not on oh I died I will I flipped out
man
if you ever jerk off you see my god
maybe I'm not a big guy you know III you
know I pick my moment and then it's like
when I do it's it's a party you know but
some guys are like I got a buddy he's
like dude got a jerk-off every day
sometimes two three times yeah that's
too much man SFO or listeners and I'm
like 80 days off of pornography right
now so huh
who died this past weekend I had the
first weekend on the road where I didn't
jerk off or didn't think about it Wow
the first weekend yeah in 15 years of
doing stand-up so that's how I know that
there's positive stuff and not watching
pornography oh my yeah I think that's
smart man that's an interesting you
talking about that in your stand-up - no
I just oh no not yet and when we talk
about it on the podcast a lot we have a
lot of guys you jerk off and are trying
not to so no it's never been my prime
directive that would be like most of my
life goal is try not to jerk off I was
more like no I actually want to meet a
beautiful woman in like try to you know
actually have sex with a woman now for
many years that was my honey I don't
touch myself oh I had that goal and you
know a jerk off in this ruin that goal
you know I was sitting there ruin him
own goal you ever just get with the girl
and then jerk off and just have it like
you know a twofer my thing now is I
don't if I have sex with a girl I'm not
coming that's fur I do that by myself so
um you know okay
because women one who does your playing
hardball you know that's how I feel dude
I'm not doing that you're not getting
that baby girl oh my god this is where
you would go to a commercial break that
would be the perfect so Lord Michaels
call yeah man you have that conversation
in Vegas you must have got off the phone
and felt pretty I was emotional you know
yeah motional because it was really you
know the kids are great yeah yeah yeah
the kid
from seventh grade that dreamt the whole
thing it was like validation boom that
day I've had a few moments in my career
where I felt like really embraced but
that standing backstage at SNL hearing
the band play being in that dark back
area looking through the beveled glass
and seeing the crowd a little bit warped
and then opening that door up and
knowing I'm I'm here cuz I did it I did
it all myself I'm not on a hit show I'm
not on a hit anything yeah I'm just a
dude it gets up there and sling some
haha for a little bit and I made it all
the way to SNL you know it shows you
anything is possible really anything is
possible man it's like just you know
whatever you want to come to fruition
it's all hard work any any time you fail
any time people don't make it to where
they they feel like they want to get to
I feel like a lot of that is
self-imposed really I think we put the
obstacles in front of ourselves yeah
yeah yeah I think that sometimes we it's
just the human condition is like we want
to you know human beings were not
exactly programmed to be just love
support and caring or else we wouldn't
have money we just be like making things
for each other all that I built a hut
feeling it it'd be dream catchers things
like this somebody sent me this neck
brace for somebody who's you know
because I always want to have a little
bit of a longer neck I got a limit it
looks like my grandma's tampon well
she's been through some tough times yeah
yeah yeah she had a huge huge honor she
must have hit her yeah there's a unique
flow she had somebody had going Wow did
you still feel then even when you're
getting on stage that these people
aren't gonna like me because I came I
did it my way or I took my own path
really I mean around that time then like
then it was you know a hundred arenas in
a row over many years so that was just
like all that like portion of my career
was just like the parade you know it was
it was just everyday waking up and
literally going who called today and
what do they want me to do and how can i
you know how can i play in the sandbox
for one more day of you know
entertainment it wasn't until you know
everything finally hit that upper upper
crest right around like 2010 and then as
it started to come down the other side I
remember feeling like okay so I had my
moment and now I it's literally going
like like our act after a certain amount
of time its passe and we're a new comic
again and I was a new comic again I was
ready for the next chapter and I didn't
mind that it wasn't gonna be as
white-hot for a little bit did you have
a moment at the top at when he started
to come down the other side we were like
did you feel like you had friends did
you feel like you had people around you
like ya used to feel like you still had
like comedians that were on your side or
yeah the point was it I mean I had the
guys that I you know Eddie Murphy came
to see good luck Chuck he came to
support my movie and I felt like maybe
not again my graduating class yeah very
tight very you made I made it with a lot
of guys you know fortunately like a lot
of guys in our group has had and
continue to have really wonderful
success and yet the guys that were in
front of me you know Richard Lewis and
Jerry Lewis and you know dice and all
these people that I had wanted to
emulate made me feel like a man so okay
this part of it to write this is
actually the part of the career that
gets interesting because then all that I
was just talking to dice last night or
text him back and forth I said you know
this is the stuff that makes rolls like
when he was in blue jasmine or star was
born the vulnerability comes from these
years comes from the stuff that happens
on the in-between you know if I wanted
to go back and play Madison Square
Garden I I know I can do it I know
exactly how to put myself right back in
that but where I'm at now and these
beautiful theatres and connecting with
people in a really unique way 29 years
in is is more I'm more enthusiastic
about that than thinking about what I
what I did you know ten years ago or
years ago you know now when you say that
you can when you say that like so you
just said like doing those roles and
being vulnerable was there was there a
moment like on the calm down part like
on that you know when it because you can
only get so high ya know there's only so
many stay there perseus yes right
was there a moment on the comedown part
where it was like because it became like
people would say like like you it became
like yeah it wasn't just like oh what
where's Dane Cook been or that sort of
thing or what's going on with Dane Cook
it was like people kind of turned
against you well it was the exact
opposite of how much of a spectacle it
was when I arrived it the pendulum
always swings exactly huh yeah so it was
like I'm not gonna be just called like
oh he's done it's gonna be like he never
was yeah he doesn't exist in the in in
the annals of stand-up comedy it's like
you know or the annals the annals or the
anals either either when trust me you
get [ __ ] a lot well there is a
necessity there is some fucked-up stuff
in this industry where it's like if
you're not just like a joke writer and
you don't fit into this certain formula
that you know that a lot of people who
run the industry think is like this is
what's funny then you're not funny right
and I hate that [ __ ] yeah me because the
funniest guys are the people that make
people laugh the most that's what I
think and that's what the ruling always
should be and now it's gotten even worse
now it's like you have to be not funny
and politically correct right which has
just led to basically people just
reading thorough onstage codes because
comedy is in one way so corporate you
know it's because it's a Philly it used
to be a dark thing in a basement where
everybody would go and sneak into and it
was like here's where you're gonna hear
the things that we're all thinking and
somebody needs to say it and now it's
it's sponsored and it's Viacom and it's
it's a business it's a whole different
thing
I'm a purist I'd like the idea of coming
into the club you know no phones you
know I like to Chapelle does nothing no
phone yeah the bags you know - Ian it's
good I love that man it's like this
should be a place where we can all come
in and hang out and air some stuff out
doesn't mean that it's a place to go in
and be racist or be [ __ ] you know
well maybe you I mean look bro I'm not
racist unless you are you know what I'm
saying brother what do you got you save
that for later
um but wasn't it fun
used to be able to be a little bit
racist and even if you knew as a
communion as entertaining you were gonna
be able to get people of that race on
board if people still listen there is
still is room for that the whole thing
is not everybody can do a joke that's so
beyond the the line of what decency not
everybody's gonna get away with that but
there are people out there because they
don't have malice in their heart and you
know they're not coming at it from a
place of being derogatory they're coming
at a place of being expressing something
we're all kind of feeling something
that's running through all of us I let
that's a great comedian you know yeah
but I don't I don't that's [ __ ]
hogwash all this stuff about and I had
it so much growing up all the alt comics
you know for a period of time they I was
mainstream and then I'm moving around
I'm not David Cross and everybody had
something to say about it and then when
I would try to do something different of
course it was like an outrage who was he
to think he could do a dramatic role and
people smashes and you look with a
sweater in it what are you doing now
he's an alt comic it's every all joke as
a sweater and a beard yeah so I don't
know man all that stuff comes at you and
you just go hey the only thing that
really matters is how you're being
received by that crowd I've said a
couple times recently people ask about
my career and the good or bad there's
only one thing that keeps you relevant
in comedy one word keeps you around and
if you're not that word we're not gonna
see in a little bit funny funny fills
rooms nobody's coming to go and I'm
gonna go see Dayne show again cuz it's
not funny and it wasn't funny but this
time I want to see if it's still not
funny yeah nobody is doing that people
are gonna support you people are gonna
smash you I think that a gifted
performer can can move around
Carlin nanka every comic should be going
we're all Carlin political irreverent
physical voices sound effects
farting smart that's a comedian he's the
architect he's one of the architects
prior same thing who are we to like put
each other in boxes
when it's really all about just getting
a message across using every facet of
what we are as people yeah you know wow
I got really like I felt myself get
really uh interesting man nah emotions
right no it's true let's take another
question that came in your Nicholas
school you know what's up fear what's up
Dane this is Sai from Minneapolis
Minnesota what is uh you guys have
thoughts on you know that whole Robert
Kraft you know dark arts witchcraft
whatever you want to call it what him
doing that what do you guys think of
that anyway I love the podcast gang gang
gang man he's talked about that suck off
of it here before to the Chiefs game Oh
his name was sigh yeah was its I like s
AI or sigh like like a sad you this
parents named him after a she gave birth
and she went oh I thought he was gonna
be and it's named him sigh anyway thanks
for the question side listen if you're
seventy seventy you want to get a little
rub and tug III think that should be
your prerogative
yeah the mistake he made is he shouldn't
gone to Florida should have gone to
Europe where they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah in the Europe man you as part as an
appetizer dude you know that come with
the water but yeah look everybody's been
jerked off somewhere by somebody they
didn't know if they wanted them to or
not well I have I miss most my child
here probably German the first time ever
you know first time it ever happened to
me into a stream like a little kind of
still water by our house and the fish
came up and ate it right in front of me
dude and I had these crazy dreams after
that for probably maybe four years so
your semen became chump oh dude you know
what I'm saying what if I thought there
was gonna be like what happens now is so
scared I was afraid to tell anybody like
what if like like fish Vaughn's came out
of the water right just a little fish
with your [ __ ] head on them yeah same
little jokes he couldn't stop coming but
yeah so everybody goes through a tough
time I think yeah look Robert Kraft is a
champion if those ladies as long as they
weren't you know being held against
their will or
something and they want to you know
perform do that type of business I don't
see anything wrong with those women
doing that type of business if they need
if they're doing it to survive and they
want to do it yeah yeah yeah the whole
human trafficking element that's not
we're talking about that's that's pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah somebody's locked in
a yeah somebody's under the influence of
drugs to be kept in an alley or
something like that like if somebody
chooses like if Theo and I said hey you
know what for a buck you can suck our
[ __ ] you know that that should be like
we're grown men we can we should be able
to make that offer yeah I mean that's a
[ __ ] yeah I would say 99 cents because
that always it's more enticing like it
ended its a businessman a marketing
right yeah and I would probably raise it
to about 20 bucks you know it comes with
a hoodie yeah it's a merge with you yeah
now we're going to Chris D'Elia cuz what
this doesn't make it easy so what he
doesn't do so yeah I saw a guy with it
doesn't make a dent hoodie on the other
day at the airport I love that man
and I was like wow it's very very cool I
saw a homeless guy wearing one of my
shirts that I always donate like extra
merch at the end of Tours and I have a
picture with this the grimy estamos dude
and he's wearing a Dane Cook sure and I
was like that's me that's my shirt and
he was like look we took a picture
that's awesome what was the question
oh the Robert Kraft yeah yeah yeah look
I mean the guy's a champion you know and
sometimes you have to relax before the
big game right and sometimes you burned
yeah that's true and his wife I think is
78 what do you bother that woman
you're gonna bother a 78 year old woman
she passed away like six years ago oh
she did yeah yeah then way [ __ ] up I
imagine you have him masturbating in a
graveyard instead because that's the
alternative man masturbating in a
graveyard should be the name of your
book someday I don't know why I could
just see you on the cover and maybe have
some fish and a little cream that are
also like watching us on the edge of the
graveyard but still you got to think
about that if that's the alternative
then look man I say we started go a go
[ __ ] me campaign for [ __ ] Robert
Kraft all right and get him what do you
need [ __ ] me that's a great idea man you
are entrepreneurial man [ __ ] what I can
I'm doing what I can man what else do we
have my god I feel hi Dean
my name is Alex Jin Lai I'm from Port
Perry Ontario and my question today is
pertaining to age in getting older I
recently just had a birthday at the
beginning of February and this was the
first year where I was dreading it and I
googled it and I saw that you guys
actually have birthday's coming up in
there back to back if Google is correct
so I'm just curious as your thoughts or
as to your thoughts on getting older and
aging and if it's something you enjoy if
it excites you if it gives you anxiety
like it gave me anxiety this year um I'm
just curious as to what you think my
favorite part of that question was when
she said if Google was correct yeah that
spoke to me more than anything else a
lot as Google is is the actor I would
keep edia yeah don't believe everything
you read on the Internet
yeah now I believe everything I read on
the internet but you're right I agree
with you both right um you got a
birthday coming up yeah March 19th 18th
really yeah fellow pisces merry z dude
very old are you gonna be I'm gonna be
39 do you look great
really yeah I don't feel great really
not really yeah I know you're good my
blood off the internet I've had some
work I had to get a good quality I had a
hair taken out of the back of here and
get into here oh okay
Oh looks great a lot of people do that
man that's really that's that's not
uncommon looks awesome yeah I've seen
other people that have and then I've
also now seen other comics ask me about
it right yeah why not right it's like if
that's that's available then hell yeah
would you ever do that would you ever do
anything you think I would do that yeah
I mean I you know for me it's like
getting older
I think it's we're lucky as men because
you know we can be distinguished and it
also adds to like okay this is I'm 46
this is the roles that I want to play
now in the kind of parts that I you know
hope to you know you know inhibit it's
like or in habit is it's it's good age
actually helps I've never been concerned
about aging
but at the same time it's like yeah I
feel like if I used to have a huge acne
scar right here and I would go and I
would get filler I'd have him do some
collagen in it cuz it was like I hated
it I didn't like my face get I had a
breeze you know what I mean yeah so I
was like and it took years to finally be
like [ __ ] it you know what I mean it's
part of me it's part of character so I'm
I'm in the I'm in I'm fully behind doing
whatever it is that you feel like you
need to do to to better health and
wellness
you know whenever that is somebody said
you got calf implants was a rumor that
went around did you ever hear that dude
I don't but look at these accounts bro
oh my god bro it looks like my friend
Ben look at that I'm like a Clydesdale
yeah I never had calf implants but I've
always had huge cab in fact I'm holding
up all that stress a bit my mom I
remember years you know years and years
ago I said what was it like when you
gave birth to me she goes your calf
ripped the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ] dude you
probably had f1 come out person-one come
out after huh there's no way you were
breech dude nobody could have [ __ ]
handled that I actually I think it was
one of those things where she she she
want to do like a c-section
yeah but they were like your cat either
way these things are gonna [ __ ] hurt
something's gonna get stressed take for
your ribs out lady you're gonna be the
next Marilyn Manson up people yeah
people ask me did you ever hear that did
that you guys have implants yeah man
I've heard a lot of crazy [ __ ] you know
people think [ __ ] everybody has like
that thing where they'll write you'd be
like hey the rumor going around that you
tweeze your eyebrows and you you get
them like whatever they call that you
know oh I would baby I mean yeah I mean
I guess at some point I would look into
some of that I laid it I got some long
ones
yeah it's threading or yeah yeah what
what people don't realize is like when
you're 46 is the stuff you learn as you
get older the hair on the they call this
the crown part like starts to diminish
yeah so it's not that like I'm so it's
like I'm [ __ ] aging yeah I'm 46 hey
guess what someday [ __ ] I might not
have any I'd be like Whoopi Goldberg
yeah
right do you um yeah I guess AG I get a
little bit scared I realized I need to
do like I want to get in shape before I
do a special now because I just want to
be able to move a little bit better on
stage and be at my most fluid sure so I
can you know like physically do things
better I noticed my body will do more
for me and will take me to new places
like sometimes I'll do something if I'm
in really feeling good then I'll do
something then we'll create some of my
brain or rings like oh you can do this
idea right
and so I'm learning that a little bit
new yoga that they help each other out
up try to do a lot of yoga
Yoga is great yeah keeps keeps you so
limber and you know cuz I've always been
very physical I don't throw my body
around I'm not doing like [ __ ] drop
kicks in houma Pilates anymore on stage
and some of that insanity because it
would hurt but but just you know going
to the gym keeping yourself healthy man
that's yeah that's another tool to your
performance ya know if you can do that
some people go the other way game
[ __ ] 150 pounds and that's funny too
yeah you know greatest part about aging
is that as a comedian it's all funny
right it's all funny if you're if you
embrace it
yeah if you don't mind being like got
the little punch go and it's all it's
all funny well I got that limited build
I'm built like a kind of stoke a wagon
and people and we've talked about this
before you know I don't have that really
I wish I had kind of wider shoulders
have limited neck range so I've always
you know had different things I wanted
to do I used to wear a neck brace at
night all the time try and get my neck
longer you know get longer yeah I try to
hold on get yourself yeah a little not
much I'm not trying to [ __ ] wait was
it like much I have to hold my [ __ ]
head up or I was gonna say you put it on
and was there like a winch that would
turn and it was like no it would just
kind of you know it make you really be a
taut right you're more rigid I like to
get a little bit taught to let it know
that I'm in business that was kind of my
goal I noticed that about you kind of a
terminator thing that's that's happening
yeah why does have limited family comes
from you know people weren't really
looking around staying [ __ ] Santa
local they were just looking straight
ahead all the time yeah there's no
[ __ ] hindsight there's no before that
I good man side sights yeah like that
zero peripheral vision and like past my
family my whole legacy was they were
looking into a
in glass ale for most of it and you know
just can't wait to get that in their
belly instead of [ __ ] looking out
let's take one more up do this is a
question for Dane I wanted to ask you
why you got kicked out of the Laugh
Factory in Los Angeles and Theo if you
had any close calls to getting booted
out of the Laugh Factory I know as a big
comedian area for comedians in Los
Angeles gang gang yeah amen and I don't
know is that true do you get that's
where Google is you know Google gets it
wrong a lot because I don't know if
people realize this breaking news
anybody that posts anything on Google
that says they're their reporter so
these days yeah fine it's a place and it
stays up there and if a lot of people
click on it the algorithm goes that must
be reality yeah you know he says on my
[ __ ] Wikipedia that my my father was
a potato farmer was he no never but if
people kept voting it up or you know I
think there was like a mob of people
that was like let's put some
misinformation in there yeah and they
valid live in vain Dane's life of the
some veggies laugh factory thing it's I
wish it was an exciting story it was not
all the hullabaloo of getting banned for
life and all that I known the owner for
17 years we had a falling-out it
literally was like it was what men do
kind of moment it was just like guys the
way guys sometimes fight and then our
relationship is actually enhanced by the
fact that we both allowed each other to
vent and [ __ ] you know have the
swagger two years went by talked to
Jamie
the owner gene Mossad him he's like I
love you buddy I'm like I love you too
I was there that Saturday night and you
know it was just two guys that after
many years of business together
successful business together had a
difference of opinion yeah and our
philosophies man that's the thing that
people don't realize philosophies change
your Constitution is different from mine
what we're trying to do is find a place
that we're you know where we are both
being received and understood you know
for what we're trying to put into say
our career is that something a common
ground but away from that you know it's
our differences that that
or actually I think even more
interesting so yeah you know you're very
vastly different from me and good that
should be the way it is right yeah what
are you uh what are you most excited
about with the upcoming tour I mean you
said that obviously you know like people
are coming out on the saying oh wow I
didn't think that I would have a new
experience with you right but I had that
yeah I think that well first of all what
feels entirely you know I haven't I
haven't people say like I was gonna come
back I never stopped I was still touring
but I just wasn't doing like a live
nation you know that put a name on it
shoot a special during it I hadn't had
one of those years since troublemaker
which was four years ago
and so being out there now the thing
that's the most that I'm most enthused
about the show is an amazing show the
show is one of the best shows that I
feel like I've put together in terms of
you know what the the bullet points I
want to hit his comedy but I'm so
present Theo you know it took a long
time to not be a person who was
encumbered by the past and the things
about my youth that made me feel so
maligned and outside and different you
know and bad about myself yeah we talk a
lot about that stuff yeah I did that a
lot of years man you know even in with
success looking back why do people hate
me why did it why did that this
situation happened to me and then there
were years where it was like all I'm
doing is looking ahead I'm not even
enjoying the now the here and now what
do I got to do next why because the
expectations when you make it in this
business is like now you're paying my
mortgage kid so get out there and
[ __ ] do more of whatever it is that
you're doing you feel that
responsibility you know I had a company
with 25 people working for me I want to
make sure everybody is winning that's a
lot that's a lot more than just being a
joke slinger yeah so it's different when
it starts to become a business is play
difference yeah and then finally it you
know it's settled into about ten years
ago at being you know something where I
felt very present but this tour in
particular because of the content you
know it's really about the content
because now I can celebrate all of it I
talked about some pretty dark moments in
my life I think in the funniest way
possible I talked about some of the
high-water marks in a way that's
self-effacing take the piss out of
myself
yeah I can [ __ ] with my success and I
can tell you why that wasn't a failure
yeah and I can do that in a funny way
yeah tell it like it is tor you know and
that's the name of the tour tel like it
is because that's that's what I'm doing
yeah do you feel um
what do you think is helping you get
more introspective over the time therapy
you know did some great therapy EMDR
anything like that mmm no I just did
like you know guilt one on one yeah yeah
after my parents died I didn't know how
to grieve I didn't know what that was I
ignored it I just did more shows and
just like kept truckin I was just like
Forrest Gump when he just ran for two
[ __ ] years yeah I just didn't stop
and then one day I was really sad and I
was like I was uh I was I remember I was
like real broken and it just hit me it
was almost just like the flu the way it
just it like entered my body and I was
like I miss my parents
mm-hmm I lost him too soon they're not
here I couldn't call him anymore to be
like what do I deal with you know all
this backlash or all this adulation I
couldn't call him anymore right and that
really hurt me deeply
yeah that's heartbreaking yeah well it
really was and I lost my brother you
know essentially my brother died because
of all that you know you know all that
craziness so it was like I went through
this period of my life where I needed
help I need somebody help me connect the
dots so I actually found a therapist who
was an agent many years ago he got it he
understood the business he's not that
not the comedy guy right I didn't go
back to him yeah
what about did what did you feel like
you had like out of time on your career
got so busy that did you feel like did
like disappointing yourself that you
hadn't spent more time with your family
there in that well I still had an
amazing connection with my mom and even
if I couldn't you know physically be
with her out we talked all the time
right
you know and she came to a lot of shows
if I had seven shows in New England she
was at all seven alone drinking Kahlua
sombreros man and [ __ ] heckling me
I'm honest too heckled me from the back
of the room literally yell things out
like talk about the night you walked in
what
I was having sex with your father and
then another person would go hey shut up
and then I'd go no you shut the [ __ ] up
that's my mom she can say whatever she
wants it was like an act of this this
whole thing so that was that was brutal
but the the gift of therapy you know
some people think like ah no it's it's
hooey it's hokey it's it is not as a
person who sat in that seat week after
week after week or on the phone if I was
on the road to be able to purge yourself
of some of those negative thoughts yeah
mmm man it was a life changer oh yeah I
got there every day at 5:00 I'll go with
you and I'm excited like oh we've heard
a lot about you in here like oh this
really is runs place-to-place you I
won't say a word but everyone so all you
just hear me go like this mm-hmm yep did
um and had a question for you were just
talking about your mom you're talking
about therapy yeah just getting getting
present you know being in the moment
being being you know in that on stage
and off yeah you know where it didn't
who I was off stage who didn't matter it
who I was on stage didn't dictate my
importance in life offstage and my
insignificance in life didn't I didn't
take that onstage to impede on my act
mhm a healthy balance of both you know
it takes a while yeah
takes it takes it takes a good long it's
you were on this road for a long time
man and look at Garry Shandling you know
that that documentary was so funny yeah
I need to watch it should watch it man
yeah wait watch the other one you talked
about the documentary not interrupt you
I don't wanna forget you talked about
the documentary about the dude that saw
the UFOs mm-hmm yeah it's on Netflix
right now no iTunes so I on iTunes UFOs
and I got to get the exact name of it
but blew my mind
what greatest documentary about UFOs
that I've ever seen all that stuff yeah
and this like I already believed it and
now I super believe it that's even a
turn
you there yeah you really he seemed like
a reliable source this man yeah cuz the
documentary isn't that's it
wait no is that it nope no no this guy's
name is I think it had his name in it
yeah it did it was it's on iTunes it's
like the number one documentary right
now the aliens arrived UFO TV that's
right see all these other things are
kind of like both the narrator's like
this they were tall and they had eyes
that were like onyx stones and you're
like oh this is this is about Egypt oak
just hokey no this is like a real guy
who did all the research talk to the
right people and Mullins or something
was his name I can't remember you're so
[ __ ] amped about it when I saw you to
come be still I was like I skipped lunch
that is me hot Ram
I can't memory sorry no it's alright
they'll find him let's play one more
question and then we'll wrap it up hey
Theo hey Jane I have a question for both
of you when was the moment that you two
found out about each other and then also
maybe the moment that you two met I want
to hear your first stories and first
impressions thanks King gang hey real
quick before we answer that we never you
never got to respond to I told you no
SNL what about you and your comedy
career at this point what's been a
moment that was will impact you for the
rest of your life somewhere you felt you
turned a corner okay let's just take
this you know I don't know actually
that's a good question I I think for me
it had a lot to do with starting to get
accepted by other comedians and it
wasn't something that happened on stage
it was probably more stuff that happened
like offstage and what do you think
ingratiated you with people what was it
about you that you felt like you were
connecting in terms of like was it just
conversations you were having with
comics or were you spending time like
bowling with them like what was I think
it was just doing comedy you know and uh
earning their respect is a consistent
performer yeah yeah because I'd ever
always
didn't like it when guys like there's a
lot of guys who seem like they were glad
hand and like leeching on people and
stuff and that was never my way I never
I in fact I wanted to I would not
communicate with comedians that were
doing well because I didn't want to be
that person and because I felt like I
couldn't hide the fact that that's what
I was trying to do if I was trying to do
it so I just kind of naturally would
meet people you know actually start
getting into some podcast and really
helped like getting on the fighter and
the kid and being able to be a guest on
their podcast for me made me feel like
oh well I get to you know joke around
with these in these fun groups right and
then one night Rogan texted me or sent
me a DM in his podcast is you know
probably the biggest one and yeah and he
just said hey man I'd love to have you
on the podcast and I remember that night
just feeling like [ __ ] man this is crazy
dude we're doing write him back to
writing back now I'm like texting like
my friends what it was like say thanks
and then say something or they might not
say something it did you say thanks dude
got jerked off bro and I was like I'm
waiting it's in the morning of course
into it into a creek yeah I know you man
I know your style defeat of that's a
huge moment you know that because you
know what that is that's that's but I
felt accepted the community saying you
know you're and I had moments like that
very early in Boston where I finally
felt like oh they know that I'm really
here to work I'm you know I love this
the art of stand-up comedy I'm a student
of it you know it takes a long time for
your peers to because we're all a little
suspicious well yeah you know who's the
who's the new guy or girl coming in
especially if they come from any other
background a little weird about it
yeah and that's nature something that's
just nature the person of a different
background you think that oh how could
they be funny they're not from the same
ilk
like what time David Arquette came in
and was like I'm a stand-up now and he
was doing all these spots of the factory
and we're all like watching going like
yeah we love scream man but what the
[ __ ] are you doing you know that's a
spot that somebody who really wants to
do this cover you know so what if did
you ever have did you was in my
impression just I can answer yeah
quickly I heard about the offer
you know quite some time yeah I think I
saw you one night performing at one of
the clubs and I remember feeling like oh
this guy really I've heard
a lot of bottom and I remember thinking
to myself oh this guy he gets it he
really gets it like I cuz I'm always see
the the gears turning with calm I can
watch and I you know I kind of like
we're a little bit soothsayer because we
know that I see what he's trying to get
to her what he's trying to and instill I
had that preconceived notion until we
finally actually chatted for a little
bit in a couple of clubs and then really
got to know each other at my house to
where I could go okay this is a
well-rounded guy who's trying to you
know figure it all out and then put it
all back into his comedy so that's I
think we started off a friendship I'm no
Rogan yeah don't text me in the middle
of the night you know he's never texting
and saying what do I say to Dane it's
lighter but that's okay that's okay
I think yet for me I would see you at
the clubs and like I always got it I
always feel like too nervous to talk to
some guys or I feel nervous around I'm
just insecurities about myself to even
just be myself so you know I probably
felt like that sometimes you were
friends with other guys that I knew
pretty well and and so you know we
bumped into each other we would talk a
little bit at the improv here and there
had a couple of conversations and then
and but that was it but the first time I
saw you that dublin's actually I mean
years ago where the first night I ever
came out watch comedy in LA oh wow
that's a great question it there yeah
and it was cool it was that was a whole
that was where everything was starting
to change me yeah that's where I was
really like oh man okay that was a world
that was a place in its own yeah yeah
yeah that when people still talk about
that yeah but Bluma Dublin's man yeah
dude that was crazy right great memories
um was there ever a chance since you're
from Boston and Wahlberg is from Boston
that there was a chance for you and Mark
Wahlberg to do a movie um no I've never
I mean I've met him several times the
closest I ever came to ever performing
those he was in the New Kids on the
Block back when I was starting stand-up
in a comedy group and we did shows
together Wow
so we would open for new kids on the
block at like sober clubs yeah who play
sober closer you're too young so we play
you know these non alcohol then use and
so Joey McIntyre was like [ __ ] 11 or
whatever he was and probably [ __ ] I got
to know [ __ ] man chicks were lining
up for those guys I was lining up in a
wig we just wanted
we just wanted to uh you know whatever
whatever fell off the side of the stage
for them we were like you know hoping
that maybe one girl would would like us
and want to touch her peen what did you
ever you ever offended that they didn't
reach out to you cuz you get both from
the same place no I mean I'd the first
film I ever did was in a movie with Ben
Affleck and Matt Damon it was called
school ties I didn't have a significant
role in it but those guys were like I
knew I knew in an armed Boston they were
emerging you know I didn't hear in that
me neither
I mean I mean it literally for like that
much dude Kurt Fox's in the patriot did
you know that yeah yeah I see he's in
one of my favorite movies wider he's in
Wyatt Earp a lot he's really great in
he's really great man but no I never
felt I've worked with many Boston guys
that you know I I've admired and come up
like him so if they called you go great
and if not then you know it's okay I'm
still a Fame yeah yeah cool stuff man
anything else guys are you shooting a
special I'm gonna film a couple of
things this year I think that I got two
two specials that I want to do and if I
can do it back-to-back then I'm gonna do
that but I don't want to give up where
I'm gonna do it yet I'm talking to
directors now and it's getting exciting
and I'm planning on doing one and doing
it myself with a with as a director and
maybe even doing it at the main room at
the comedy store because I feel so
comfortable there of course do you think
it matters like venue size and that sort
of thing I mean for me some of it seems
of it to be about comfort like the last
one I did was in a place it was in a
theater and it was okay but it wasn't
really that comfortable I'd never even
been on the stage right so it didn't
feel I was very nervous yeah but uh yeah
I know I don't think it matters
whatsoever I mean honestly I feel like
comedy is as long as it's you know got
great sound you know even more than
lights or anything as long as it sounds
great you know if you're at a place that
you're comfortable hometown of course
that's a legendary room in an amazing
room just a room that embraces comedy so
I think that's a smart moving your part
playing it there but I don't I don't
think that you know it's not like saying
hey because you played a five thousand
cedar that that
you should have more of a validation or
less it's like know if you're funny that
should be wherever that you want to do
that is gonna work out
funny wins funny wins tell it how like
it is don't like it is tell it like it
is you're yeah we're out there man did
I'm gonna med for it actually in two
weeks are you serious yeah oh [ __ ] I'm
so excited I'm nervous or bought you
know Boston I'm just yeah I'm excited
and nervous right next to my my town
that I grew up in really yeah yeah born
and raised in Arlington Massachusetts
and used to hang out at the Medford Mall
really yeah look for chicks they were
coming out of [ __ ] parade of shoes
yes they're on a bench eating Brigham's
ice cream going like girls they wouldn't
look at me for another 10 years but you
already know we used to camp out at the
mall we should drop to Slidell Louisiana
and we'd go stay at the mall you had a
tent camp out outside and go to the mall
again the next day
was you have a store that was like your
spot that you always had to go like I
got to go to the sharper image or oh
yeah yeah we went to the place that have
like panties but also have like lava
lamps what is a oh yeah yeah we steal a
bunch of stuff and then get arrested
even sometimes it arrest you then let go
and they good end alike Electronics
Boutique yeah and look at what the new
[ __ ] Nintendo 64 games just imagine
everybody cared about you to have one
was [ __ ] good to us
Dane Cook best to look on your new tour
man it's the oh thanks for having me man
yeah really I was excited for this so
would you ever do a podcast of your own
you think have you considered it or does
that seem like something that everybody
else is doing so you're going the other
direction of this I love being a guest
and coming in and having come up and
created my own early version of app I
wasn't even called a podcast I had
something called the voice of doom and
the voice of doom was a little jukebox
that I would upload mp3 and I would do
like a rant every couple days I just put
on like some stuff that I knew wouldn't
be funny as much on stage but like I
could kind of riff on yeah and I felt
like for me I I I'm enjoying watching so
many people embrace the entrepreneurial
side of getting their voice out there
way more than even if I was doing it at
this point because I'm like I did that
was not cool when it was not in vogue
and you're a big lot of [ __ ] and now
it's the template right now it's a must
the calling card so I'm just I'm
grateful that you know I could come in
here and hang out hopefully you'll have
me back yeah we'd love to you man thanks
for coming in Coleman
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]